hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kaufwelt ich mache heute wieder etwas
typisch türkisches und zwar kennen es
wahrscheinlich ganz viele die bereits in
der türkei urlaub gemacht haben
heute geht es los limmer das sind ganz
tolle teigfladen sag ich jetzt mal mit
einer leckeren füllung ich werde jetzt
mit einer spinat schafskäse führung
gefühlt aber ihr dürft ihr auch ganz
gerne andere füllung nehmen dafür und
ich mach jetzt heute zehn stück das
heißt es wird jetzt eine relativ kleine
portion ihr dürft aber gerne das rezept
auch verdoppeln oder verdreifachen und
einfach ein paar mehr machen und in der
türkei wird das traditionell auf so
einem search gemacht das kennt man ja
auch da sitzen dann so die älteren damen
an der straßenecke und backen das dann
an der straße aus oder eben auch im café
oder im restaurant und wir machen das
jetzt heute ganz normal in einer pfanne
in einer beschichteten das geht nämlich
auch und ich würde ich jetzt erstmal die
zutaten zeigen und dann legen wir direkt
los also für den teig brauchen wir 185
gramm warmes wasser
das soll jetzt einfach nur handwarm sein
und nicht wärmer als 30 grad inhalten
teelöffel zucker
ich habe ich ein stück für das in etwa
fünf gramm einen halben teelöffel salz
und ich brauche etwa zwischen 350 und
380 gramm mehl
ich habe jetzt einfach 380 abgewogen und
je nach dem brauch ich eben mehr oder
etwas weniger
das sind die zutaten für den teig und
diese hier für die füllung
ich habe hier eine zwiebel und eine
knoblauchzehe hier habe ich ein rädchen
schafskäse
da habe ich jetzt wieder den hier
genommen verbockt hat weil uns der so
richtig gut schmeckt etwas chili und
pfeffer und ich habe hier 200 gramm
spinat ich hab jetzt frischen spinat
aber ihr dürft auch ganz gerne tiefe
vorne nehmen
und ich habe hier noch etwas butter die
brauchen wir später zum bestreichen und
ich stelle jetzt erstmal den hefeteig
herd den könnt ihr jetzt entweder per
hand zu bereiten oder in der
küchenmaschine und ich mache es zeit
einfach in der kennwort weil die nämlich
eine hitze funktion hat von der koch
funktion und das ist einfach optimal
wenn man ein hefeteig herstellen weil er
dann auch direkt darin gehen kann
jetzt nehme ich mir aber erst mal meine
hefe und zerbröckelt die hier ins wasser
rein da kommt auch der zucker mit dazu
das ist einfach optimal da bekommt die
hefe dann etwas nahrung und kann einfach
besser aufgehen das wird jetzt kurz
verrührt einfach so dass sich die hefe
auflöst viele rezepte sind auch komplett
ohne hefe aber ich finde es besser wenn
da füssel hefe mit dabei ist damit der
teig einfach so ein bisschen lockerer
wird und nicht so hart wird und jetzt
gebe ich diese mischung in meine
küchenmaschine gibt da auch mein salz
mit dazu und etwa die hälfte des mehls
jetzt dürfte einfach mal weiter her
kommen und jetzt kann ich hier die
temperatur einstellen ihr seht jetzt da
steht jetzt 25 grad das heißt weil ich
aber dieses warme wasser benutzt
ich schalte sich hier auf etwa 35 grad
und das ist jetzt ganz kurz verkneten
und gibt dann einfach so viel mehl dazu
bis ebenen glatter teig entsteht
und so sollte der teig dann aussehen
also es nicht zu weich aber auch nicht
hart sondern richtig schön warm auch und
einfach geschmeidig und jetzt nehme ich
einfach den knethaken raus und nehme den
teig und formen zu einer kugel es geht
auch relativ gut weil er nicht so
verklebt hier noch ein paar reste und
diese kugel gebe ich jetzt wieder zurück
in die schüssel kann man auch vorher mit
etwas mehl aussteigen dann geht die
google später leichter raus und dann
mache ich die temperatur drauf und
stellt hier einfach auf intervall stufe
3 das heißt die maschine erhitzt aber
rührt nicht mehr
oder hört nur gelegentlich aber ohne
stab eben macht den deckel drauf und so
kann der teig jetzt etwa 10 15 20
minuten ruhen bis ich meine füllung
vorbereitet habe
zuerst werde ich jetzt die
knoblauchzehen und die zwiebeln fein
hacken
und meine pfanne habe ich da drüben
schon erhitzt und die zwiebeln sind sehr
scharf und ich glaube da ist einfach ein
bisschen olivenöl rein das habe ich
vorhin vergessen zu erwähnen
so etwa 2 3 esslöffel und da kommen
jetzt die zwiebel und knoblauch würfel
mit rein und werden bei mittlerer stufe
etwas gebräunt
also eigentlich nicht geplant sondern
eher glasig gedünstet und in der
zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal den
spinat so ein bisschen fein hacken und
falls ihr da jetzt tiefgekühlten spinat
habt müsst ihr den vorher auftauen
lassen und einfach ein bisschen
ausdrücken denn das ziemlich viel wasser
mit dabei dass er einfach diese
flüssigkeit nicht mit drin habt und am
besten liegt ihr den spinat dann nachdem
ihr die feuchtigkeit ausgedrückt habt
und als alternative füllungen könnte ich
mir jetzt vorstellen dass er entweder
zum beispiel eine kartoffel füllung
macht da habe ich auch mal ein rezept
gemacht mit taschen und kartons
füllungen
die könnt ihr zum beispiel nehmen oder
hackfleisch füllung oder einfach
irgendwas komplett anderes was euch
einfach so in den sinn kommt oder was
ihr zum beispiel auch kennen was ich
glaube ich auch ganz lecker findet wer
vielleicht zum beispiel so eine
schafskäse tomaten für luft kann ich ihn
auch ganz gut vorstellen auch was
vegetarisches oder wenn ihr zum beispiel
dem käse weg lasst und etwas mehr
schafft etwas mehr spinat nimmt könnte
daraus sogar was veganes machen also
dann besser komplett weg weil ich ja
außerdem schafskäse jetzt kein
tierisches produkt habt also discover
auch schon richtig schönes veganes
und sobald die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen angedünstet sind kann ich
jetzt den spinat dazu geben
das sieht jetzt noch relativ viel aus
aber da fällt es gleich in sich zusammen
und dann gar nicht mehr so viel übrig
und da gibt es am besten einfach kurz
den deckel drauf guckt aber dass die
zwiebeln jetzt nicht da unten verbrennen
also die am besten so ein bisschen hoch
gebe ich den deckel drauf und überhaupt
so etwa 23 minuten bis der zusammenfällt
und dann geht es gleich weiter
und jetzt nach etwa drei minuten
ich rege mich nicht mehr viel vom spinat
übrig mich verbrannt am deckel und jetzt
führe ich das einfach mal kurz durch und
es riecht hier auch schon richtig gut
nach spinat ich meine ich mag spinat
sowieso mein mann auch und deswegen
schmeckt das gigantisch gleich ich würde
das ganze jetzt nicht mit salz weil hier
jetzt gleich unter schafskäse reinkommt
und da ist auch schon salzig genug
deswegen gibt's bei mir nur chili und
pfeffer
chili können natürlich auch weglassen
wenn ihr es nicht so gern scharf mit
aber ich finde das gehört immer so ein
bisschen mehr dazu zum grundgesetz
jetzt kann ich die pfanne eigentlich
auch schon aus schalten den herd
ausschalten und das ganze durch rühren
das muss sitzen nämlich ein bisschen
abkühlen und dann werde ich da jetzt
mein job sie gleich noch rein geben und
ich warte zu etwa zehn minuten bis es
abkühlt und dann geht es gleich weiter
die spielers ist jetzt soweit ziemlich
abgekühlt und ich nehme jetzt einfach
den schafskäse und da brösel ihn da
jetzt mit der hand rein
ihr könnt natürlich auch in kleine
würfel schneiden aber ich denke so geht
es einfach schneller und mit der
handkamera arbeiten meint übrigens
mittlerweile schon ein bisschen
aufgegangen das heißt ich kann sobald
ich mir jetzt gleich die hände noch mal
gewaschen habe direkt auch starten
und wenn es jetzt einfach nur noch ganz
kurz berühren und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder auf meine arbeitsfläche wo
ich gleich den teig rolle
mein hilfe teil gesetz aufgegangen und
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal aus der
schlüssel heraus und gibt ein bisschen
mehl auf eine arbeitsfläche und jetzt
muss ich das ganze portionieren ich habe
gesagt ich mache jetzt zehn stück heraus
und so hatte der teig so etwa 500 gramm
so ein bisschen mehr als 500 und ich
werde daraus kleine stückchen form und
50 gramm
er denke zwar scheine ich bin verrückt
aber ich mir das wirklich ab weil ich
einfach will dass ihr gleichmäßig werden
deswegen als ihr könnt entweder per
augenmaß machen
oder er macht einfach auch wie ich mit
der marke
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach jedes
stückchen und formt daraus einen richtig
schönen sauberen ball
das erleichtert uns dann gleich das
ausrollen also ich nehme mir mal von
außen den teig mit den fingern und geh
nach innen und dann könnten entweder in
der hand rollen oder zum beispiel auf
der arbeitsfläche es geht beides gut
dann nehme ich dann auch kein mehl und
es geht am besten auf so nach holz
arbeitsplatte weil auf dem holztisch und
dann gebe ich mir da oben jetzt so ein
bisschen medien und damit ich sie jetzt
alle portionieren und gleich nochmal so
ein bisschen abdecken
ich hatte jetzt meine teiglinge noch mal
fünf minuten abkühlen nicht ab hier
ruhen lassen weil ich in der zeit schon
mal die palme gespült habe und jetzt
habe ich mir alles vorbereitet und ich
zeit mich jetzt einfach mal wie ich das
auch normalerweise zu hause mache weil
ich mache das ganze ziemlich zeit sparen
das heißt während ich hier noch etwas
vorbereitet backen die einen schon
ich habe hier meine pfanne dieses bett
frei und wird gleich erhitzt dann habe
ich hier meine mutter gerichtet dies
jetzt auch schon ein bisschen warm
ich brauche einen pinsel da nämlich am
besten also am liebsten immer stilikone
pinsel weil die nicht haben
die füllung habe ich mir schon
bereitgestellt mit einem esslöffel und
dann brauche ich nur noch einen
ausrutscher und ein opfer war das ist
jetzt das kennen die türken oder auch
die die dabei waren
denn das ist so ein spezieller ausrollt
staaten ganz dünner und mit dem kann man
zum beispiel diese user blätter aus
rollen oder auch baklava blätter das
habe ich ja auch schon gemacht und im
prinzip war es ist eigentlich schon ich
brauch noch im teller und stadt jetzt
einfach mal die rate ich mach das jetzt
bereit mit vier stück vor und werde die
dann schon mal in der pfanne eben braten
oder beziehungsweise backen und kann
dann in der zeit wieder die anderen
ausrollen nehme ich mir hier immer so
ein bisschen mehr
damit es nicht klebt und rollt es jetzt
erst einmal zu seinem fladen aus geht
natürlich auch mit einem ganz normalen
aus hall starb ich nehme da auch ganz
gern meinen schwarzen silikon starb mit
griffen oder kunststoff statt mit
griffin arbeiter ist kann ich da
wer das immer wieder dreht dann wird es
auch schön rund den lege ich gezielt zur
seite und macht das ganze noch dreimal
an dass ich vier stück schon bereit habe
jetzt nehme ich mir hier das weg was ich
vorhin zuerst ausgerollt haben und die
anderen denke ich jetzt auch wieder mit
einem sauberen tuch ab damit die mir
hier nicht austrocknen und hart werden
und jetzt nehme ich hier den stab und es
geht jetzt ganz einfach das erstmal
braucht ihr platz um euch herum und dann
rollt er den teig einfach ein zu sein
immer genug mehl da sein aber auch nicht
zu viel und jetzt wird einfach von innen
nach außen desto gestrichen
dann müsste es wieder öffnen bisher
drehen und wenn ihr merkt der teig wird
wieder klebrig einfach bisschen mehr
rein und jetzt immer wieder den teig
drehen und ausrollen und dass er jetzt
beginnt mit denen dann ausholen kann ich
hatte das auch damals bei meinem back
for video erwähnt mein papa hat zb
meiner mama seinen stab aus einem
besenstiel gemacht also aus einem
sauberen natürlich das geht nämlich auch
super und wenn er tat es auch in jedem
türkischen supermarkt
nein
die größe die reicht es aber vollkommen
und jetzt nehme ich da das nähe und habe
so ein bisschen abklopfen rezitiert
runter und nehmen wir das nächste
teilstück und es sieht jetzt auch den
größenvergleich also so ungefähr war es
ursprünglich und so ist jetzt und wenn
ihr das dann soweit ausgerollt habt
nehmt ihr euch jetzt diese füllung ich
nehme zu und gehäufte esslöffel und
streicht es jetzt auf eine hälfte
und wenn man das mal so sieht wie es
gemacht wird dann schätzt man das
wahrscheinlich viel mehr was man im
urlaub zu essen bekommt denn die frauen
oder die männer eine frau zu machen
keiner war in der türkei schon eine
frauenarbeit und die frauen des tab
machen machen das echt mit handarbeit
und ich weiß auch gar nicht zu welcher
region es gehört also wo das herkommt
weil in der türkei ist sehr echt extrem
dass man sagt okay die köpfe kommen aus
atome oder das lahmacun oder keine
ahnung ein anderes gericht kommt daher
und es gibt es hier eigentlich nicht
weil es eigentlich überall her kommt
glaube ich das bekommt man zumindest
überall
und wenn jemand weiß wo es wirklich
herkommt könnt ihr mir das ja gerne
schreiben aber ich finde einfach die
handarbeit sollte man dann schätzen
vor allen dingen wenn man sieht wie
viele schritte da dazwischen stecken
ich hab das jetzt übrigens hier
zugeklappt und drückt es jetzt mit den
fingern am rande noch zu
das geht auch ganz gut weil der teig
einfach nicht so trocken ist müsste halt
gut verschließen
dann sieht es jetzt so aus und so mache
ich jetzt noch die anderen drei und
falls ihr jetzt sagt messerli das mit
einem lüfter also das ist ja sowieso new
car teig das bekomme ich wirklich nicht
so dünn hin könnt ihr euch zum beispiel
auch im fertigen juka nehmen also ich
habe jetzt leider keine runden da aber
ich habe zum beispiel die dreieckigen
die hatte ich euch mal beim einem
saunabereich gezeigte sind so dreieckige
lüfterblätter das sind jetzt 260 gramm
drin als ich denke das sind vielleicht
30 stück und die gibt es aber auch nicht
geschnitten also richtig rund und die
kann man auch benutzen sie sind ein
bisserl trockener dann müsste sie
vielleicht wissen vorher mit butter oder
milch bestreichen das einfach nicht
brechen und dann könnten sie auch
benutzen also die muss man vorher wissen
nachts machen
und jetzt habe ich hier meine pfanne
bereits erhitzt und diese richtig heiß
und da lege ich dir jetzt ohne butter
ohne fett einfach rein
wenn europa eine groß genug ist können
auch gerne zwei stück reinlegen
jetzt lassen wir einfach von beiden
seiten richtig schön backen so etwa zwei
minuten pro seite also man sieht es auch
gleich die wir dann so leicht braun aber
das zeige ich euch einfach direkt
und ich finde immer ganz lustig werden
sie jetzt wie hier dann aufblähen
also es müsse nicht genau zwei minuten
sein wenn ihr natürlich merkt es braucht
schon ein bisschen und ihr müsst ihr
auch immer mal wieder drunter schauen
und wenn ihr merkt die farbe ist schon
da können das auch schon vorher umdrehen
so als ich drees mainz und so sollte es
in etwa aussehen immer auch gerne wissen
flach drücken
und ich werde die eine seite schon mal
mit der butter bestreichen das bewegt
und einfach dass dieser teigfladen
natürlich etwas weiter wird und butter
bringt dann natürlich auch noch meinen
geschmack müsst ihr natürlich nicht
machen aber original wird so einfach
gemacht was jetzt einfach so einfach die
butter hier in meiner löffel ablage dann
mache ich mir meine mutter stück hier
nicht dreckig und kann dass da direkt
raus setzen
so und jetzt nämlich aus der pfanne
heraus und geht es mit der butterseite
auf den teller kann den nächsten oder
das nächste level 1 0 in die pfanne
legen und diesen hier den fertigen auch
nochmal auf dieser seite mit butter
bestreichen und das mache ich jetzt hier
einfach so weiter und gehe aber gleich
währenddessen auch wieder rüber und
rolle meine anderen teile aus die
teiglinge denn so könnte einfach
zeitsparend arbeiten und das ganze ist
innerhalb von ungefähr einer halben
stunde fertig ich habe jetzt meine girls
lämmer alle zubereitet und ich hab jetzt
bisher also von anfang an bis jetzt etwa
eineinhalb stunden gebraucht also das
könnt ihr euch so als zeitfenster
daneben reservieren falls sie das machen
wollte ich finde die kammer einfach gut
zb zum frühstück vorbereiten oder auch
zum nachmittagstee oder auch einfach so
als beilage zum essen wir hatten sie
gestern als beilage heute gibt es die
zum späten frühstück zum brunch und ihr
könnt sie jetzt so servieren
ich habe jetzt hier zb mal so einen
serviervorschlag für euch also ich habe
es jetzt hier alle gefaltet hab sie
hingelegt mit wissenschafts käse und ein
paar oliven und gefüllten kleinen
paprika ihr könnt da zum beispiel auch
noch gurken oder tomaten mit dazu
reichen schwarze oliven also alles was
euch eigentlich am besten schmeckt ich
finde was auf jeden fall dazu gehört ist
ein richtig leckere türkische schwarztee
der muss auf jeden fall auch sein den
habe ich jetzt hier auch schon drauf
gegeben auf dem herd der essensauswahl
wer bereit der morath kommt gleich nach
hause und ich würde sagen ich wünsche
uns allen einen guten appetit und euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen
das rezept gibt es auch salehs - blog.de
und ich freue mich schon wieder aufs
nächste mal ist bald tschüss